[Müzik]
bugün karşınızda bu konuşmayı yapıyorsam
gerçekten işimi tutkuyla yaptığım için
bunu tutkuyla Bağlı olduğum içindir bana
Hep soruyorlar ya bu otomobil sevdası
nereden başladı Aslında şöyle
söyleyebilirim Ailede benim kadar
derinlemesine otomobil hayranı yoktu
Hani her erkek Tabii ki sever babam abim
severler Ama benim kadar bu boyuta
ulaşmadılar küçükken bana aldıkları
kitaplar vardı otomobiller uçaklar iş
makinaları belki burada gördüğüm temel
kavramlar temel fizik kanunları o
içimdeki tutkunun alevlenmesine sebep
oldu diyebilirim küçükken daha o zaman
mp3 yok YouTube Yok öyle rahat rahat
işte müzik dinleyemiyorsun ses
dinleyemiyorsun Benim kasetlerim vardı
motor sesleri barındıran kasetlerim
içinde V8 işte karbüratörlü V12 Ferrari
sesleri Motosiklet sesleri onlara
dinleye dinleye büyüdüm diyebilirim bu
tabi benim Artık İçime işlem genelde
sokakta otomobil görünce sesinden
tanıyorum işte lastiğine baktığım zaman
marka model hangi hız sınıfı olduğunu
biliyorum
değişik bir boyut almaya başladı Yani
öyle bir şey Tutku yıllarca içim yanıp
tutuşuyor otomobil kullanmak için daha
boyum yetmiyor Ama sürekli Annemi babamı
izliyorum Ne yapıyorlar ne ediyorlar
diye
Sonra gün geldi çattı ehliyetimizi aldık
otomobil kullanmaya başladım süper böyle
her şeyi biliyorum teorik olarak
bildiğimiz zannediyormuşum ki ufak
birkaç Kazadan sonra gördüm ki Aslında
daha yolun başındayız hiçbir şey
bilmiyorum
bundan sonra anladım ki bu konuyu çok
daha derinlemesine araştırmam öğrenmem
gerekiyor Onun için
katılabildiğim kadar pist günlerine
kendi otomobilimine katıldım bütçemin el
verdiği eğitimlere katıldım ya bu bir
süreç zaten hani bir eğitime katılınca
Hemen olmuyor sürekli sürekli sürekli
sürekli sürekli üstüne koyman gerekiyor
ve bu şekilde kendimi geliştirmeye
çalıştım
Tabii bununla beraber artık bu tutkuyu
işim haline getirmek istiyorum hani ne
yapayım hep Babam da makine mühendisi
makine mühendisi vardı hep aklımda çünkü
hani sadece otomobil sevmek değil
aslında iş makinesi da seviyorum uçağa
da seviyorum hidroliği de seviyorum
makine mühendisliği okudum
bununla beraber öğrencilik yıllarımda
kendi harçlıklarımda Hatta Hani ailemden
gizli şekilde bir tane Ford Taunus aldım
4 sene sonra baktığım zaman bin liraya
aldığım arabaya 10 bin lira masraf
etmiştim ama işte o 10 bin lira belki de
bugünlerin temelini attı diyebilirim
Çünkü o güne kadar Tutkun olduğum
araştırdığım her şeyi o otomobil
üzerinde pratik etme fırsatı buldum
söktüm taktım yani sorun çıktığında
mutlu oluyordum işte ev arkadaşımla
kalkıyorduk hemen girişiyorduk
bozuyorduk yapamıyorduk öğreniyorduk
dediğim gibi artık iş böyle Tutku
mesleğin haline de dönüşmeye başlıyor
zaten zaten ya mesleğin olacak ya da
Hobi olarak devam edeceksin ben mesleğim
olmasını seçtim
kendinizle daha iyi insanlarla vakit
geçirdikçe hem vizyonunuz gelişiyor hem
de yani otomobil tutkusu Daha da artıyor
Aslında alevleniyor Ondan sonra artık
bir ikinci vitese atma zamanı gelmişti
bu da Risk almak bence
risk almayan kendi hayatının kahramanı
olamaz ama tabi akılcıl riskler alarak
Ben kurumsal bir firmada otomotivde
çalışıyordum
Tabi bir yandan da YouTube maceramız
başlamıştı kitle gitgide artıyor Biz
geceleri video çekiyoruz işten sonra
artık mesela iş yemeğine gidiyoruz Orada
garson tanıyor abi ise vererek izliyoruz
falan ya şimdi yanımda müdür var artık
tabi hani kaçınılmaz noktaları doğru
gidiyoruz Bir sözlü uyarı aldım ikinci
sözlü uyarı aldım Ondan sonra yazılı bir
İhtar Aldım ya şimdi Tabii empati
kurunca Haklılar yani otomobil videosu
çekiyorsun otomobil
firmasında çalışıyorsun olmaz zor yani
tabii Ben yılmadım bir sene boyunca
kafamda kask kamera hiç gözükmeden
videolar çekmeye devam ettim ondan sonra
artık işi öyle bir hal almıştı ki
Öğle arasında toplantıya gidiyorum
yıllık iznimi kullanıyorum proje
çekimine gidiyoruz artık işimiz haline
gelmeye başlamıştı Artık bir karar verme
zamanı da gelmişti ya istifa edecektim
ya da kurumsal firmada devam edecektim
ama tabii ki tutkumuz ağır bastı ve
istifa ettim bundan sonra tabi artık
yalnız başına
işi
devam ettirmen gerekiyor eşin var
Çocuğun olacak tabi Burada önemli bir
nokta eşinin ailenin de sana destek
olması Sağ olsunlar hep arkamda oldular
artık işi döndürmen gerekiyor hani ne
yapacağım daha Çünkü biz Hani bugünlere
gelene kadar birçok engelle karşılaştık
en basiti en temel Şeyi test arabası al
firmalardan çok kiraladığımı
hatırlıyorum havaalanından ofislerden
Hatta komik bir anımı anlatayım yine bir
firmadan test arabası almak istiyoruz
mailler falan yani bir iletişim yok geri
dönmüyor maillere kimse sonra ta ki
bizde o zaman böyle Tek Yürek
takipçilerle imza kampanyası başlattılar
3004000 imza toplandı ortalık ayağa
kalktı sonra tabii ki markanın da
dikkatini çektik işte kurumsal iletişim
müdürüyle bir toplantı yaptık
derdimizi anlattık O bize derdini
anlattı ortak bir paydada buluştuk ha
dedik ki şunu gördük ki iletişimle o
aradaki duvarlar kalkabiliyor Çünkü biz
de bir mesafeliydik insanlar da Tabii
ona göre mesafeli oluyor
dedik ki iletişimle Biz bu işi çözeceğiz
çok önemli hakikaten çok önemli Her işte
ne olursa olsun yani ıq'nuz çok yüksek
olabilir Çok iyi bir üniversiteden mezun
olabilirsiniz ama iyi ki Yani duygusal
yapay zekanız Bence daha önemli
gerçekten daha önemli
iş mülakatlarına gittiğiniz zaman tamam
çok güzel CV harika Ama ne yaptın stajı
nerede yaptın sosyal sorumluluk
projesinde çalıştın mı tiyatro hobiler
nedir Aslında orada seni
duygusal zekanı çözmeye çalışıyorlar
nedir Hani bu ayak uydurabilecek mi
Çünkü mühendis olarak başlarsın rotasyon
olur pazarlamada devam edersin Hani
esnek misin Ama onu biraz çözmeye
çalışıyorlar tabii
dediğim gibi iletişimin gücünü orada
anladık
benim hikayemden yola çıkarak Bence
benim başarımı reçetesi
akılcıl risker almak işimi tutkuyla
yapmak
derinlemesine öğrenmek ve iletişimi çok
ama çok iyi tutmak Siz de tutkunuzun
peşinden gidin akılcıl riskler alın ve
kendi kahramanınız olun beni
dinlediğiniz için teşekkür ederim
Görüşmek üzere
[Alkış]